Reddit asked me to ask you to tell me
the story of Chess Bay the Reddit
moderator who pitted you against Eric
Hansen uh also known as chess bro I'm
just saying things I don't know I don't
know much about air cans I guess Eric is
another grand master you guys had some
uh drama and tension between each other
so we'll also ask you to tell me what
you like best about Eric Hansen as a
human being here's what I was like the
the whole stream streamers and the whole
boom of Chess there are certain people
certain entities that are very very
important to what happened
um you know there are a lot of people in
the right place at the right time myself
botez the chess bras I love you as well
we were all kind of in the right place
at the right time but just having the
personalities alone is not enough you
need people who push things and
um there are a lot of things that have
been said about Chess Bay about what she
did at the end of the day the way that I
view it is pretty straightforward you
don't have to agree with what she did
the man manner in which she did things
but it pushed the game it pushed the
directory and chess on Twitch forward in
a way that would not have been possible
with anybody else at the time chess.com
for example they were not directly
um pushing it so you needed someone
who's pushing it and that so to me when
I look at the whole boom actually of
what happened on Twitch in many ways I
think she's just as responsible as I was
Levy was botes was in the bras were all
of us were extremely fortunate because
if you didn't have someone pushing it
forward and charles.com was not really
that involved at the time it never would
have gotten to where it was so you can
sort of look at it and say okay you
don't agree with what happened but you
needed someone like that who was going
to push push really hard to get just to
where it is today
can you comment on what happened for
people who have no clue what you were
talking about is that not useful I I
don't think it's specifically useful to
get into it I think there are a lot of
layers
um people felter things like abuses of
power things of that nature there were a
lot of things that were said
um you know I don't want to be super
negative about about what happened
specifically but one thing people will
note
um is that prior to what did happen in
April of 20 I think that was 2021 now uh
there were a lot more collaborations the
Chess World was much more together as a
whole a lot of streamers did things
together after what happened in April
there was a big sort of Separation a lot
of streamers went off in their own
directions because of what happened
um so that is I mean that's not the
whole story there's a lot more to it of
course but I think it's fair to say that
I if I can just comment on the few times
I've tuned into the streaming world I do
hate to see the the silos that were
created one of the reasons I've been a
fan and now a good friend of uh Joe
Rogan you call it collaborations because
basically everybody's supporting each
other gets excited for each other
promotes each other and there's not that
competitive feeling with with streamers
sometimes I've just noticed that there's
a
natural siloing effect I don't know why
that is exactly
um maybe because drama is somehow
good for views and clicks and that kind
of stuff I don't know what that is but I
hate to see it because I love seeing
kind of
friendship and uh uh collaborations I
think this also goes like again try not
to be super negative but this also goes
to the Chess World as a whole like one
of the things that I've been in this
trust world for a very long time not
talking about online but just like the
Chess World itself and I've been very
fortunate because I've seen a couple
booms and busts like in the late it
actually wasn't late 90s it was in the
mid 90s there was a period of time when
Intel and IBM and all these tech
companies were very big on chess there
there were there's this PCA Grand Prix
World Championship held in New York
um there there also were I think there
was like the deep blue stuff later on in
the late 90s with Gary Gary Kasparov um
and you had a lot of interest at the
time and then it sort of went went up in
Flames for a couple different reasons
also in the late late 2000s or maybe
mid-2000s there was a group in Seattle
that was very big on chess they hosted
the US Championship all these different
things there have been a lot of booms uh
booms and busts of course if you go way
back there was the Fisher boom as well
um but inevitably what leads these bus
and the thing that leads to it is at the
end of the day people in the trust world
have this natural tendency to want to
not work together you want to hang on to
whatever whatever piece of the trust
world you have as opposed to thinking
about it from the standpoint of what's
good for one is good for all and so it's
one of those things that now that I'm in
this situation having seen these booms
of us I I remember when I was younger I
would very oftentimes think like why is
it the chest isn't bigger why do we
struggle so much to to grow the game and
I think you know we we see the reason so
now when I'm in this this position it's
also very tough because like I know
what's happened you try to learn from
the past
um but you still it still feels very
hard to uh break out from that it feels
very tough and it's also difficult
because another thing that people kind
of misunderstand is from time to time
I'll talk about myself I'll actually
talk about Levy and incomes or how well
we're doing and the main reason I talk
about this is that I wanted to inspire
like feeding the governing bodies and
others feel like wow these people are
having such success like we we surely we
can do something different we can change
change things and somehow it has not
happened which is in a way very very
disheartening to me because I want to
see more interest in chess you know you
want to see more sponsors more more the
general public getting excited by the
game so it is one of those things that's
very very difficult yeah so you want to
see Innovation on the parts of everybody
but also the organizations like vdhs.com
right to uh how to inspire a large
number of people which is what this is
what streamers are doing they're
constantly innovating I guess of how how
to reach very large audience before we
forget just to put a little love oh you
want me to ask about error yeah yeah
yeah a little love out there what do you
like best about Eric Hansen as a human
being
um I think he's it's mainly he's just
he's very he's very charismatic he's
very charismatic he he knows the the
brand that he has and he's he doesn't
like he doesn't pretend to fake it like
he knows what his brand is and and he
owns it so he's uh just for people who
don't know and I don't know he's a grand
master yeah he's a strong Grandmaster
but he's also like a Creator yeah one of
the one of the earliest major chess
content creators on Twitch like
educational stuff too uh a mix mix of
educational mix of high level everything
yeah